how you doing man super good man let me
show you a few things real
quick this is the car I've owned the
longest the SLR McLaren Roadster por
Speedster turbo the SL65 Black Series
get that one from you I'm trying to get
that one from you n a getting that one
when did you start collecting cars in my
mind when I
was n years old I don't want to see
myself on the road you know what I'm
saying the Fisker the 964 RS they only
made that in Europe and this is a gtx1
this is my baby I love the for GT I love
the GT to have a hard top removable top
which makes it really unusual Michael's
cars come from every era but there was
one vintage ride I had my eye on the
whole time front and center a 1975 Aston
Martin Vanquish woo Jane B I throw a
tuck seat on in this one this is7 this
is7 yeah7 this the number one stunner
well I appreciate y'all man what y'all
are doing here is fantastic I appreciate
the father son love man inspires me hope
Inspire the other people who see it
thank you
man brother all love for you all
[Music]
brother